on connaîtra bientôt la sélection
régionale du concours des villes
fleuries de france un label très
recherché et apprécié des municipalités
les espaces verts font désormais partie
intégrante du cadre de vie urbain à
dijon le service des espaces verts créé
en 1971 gère 600 hectares de parc et
quelques 8000 arbres annick alexandre et
jean paul garnier se sont intéressés à
la partie la plus colorée de ce
patrimoine vert les fleurs des fleurs
habille la ville matif coloré et spark
chatoyant il faut que tu l'aies ruban
gris du bitume des rues comme autant de
signes à présent offert aux regards
stressé des citadins fait de culture le
fleurissement est devenu un élément
essentiel du confort de la vie urbaine à
dijon les espaces verts représente un
investissement important 6 % du budget
global de la ville installée sur 8 ha
car c'est des valendons près de 200
personnes y sont employées sous la
houlette d'andré au l'audace qui est
ingénieur horticole paysagiste le
printemps l'été l'automne sont les trois
périodes de floraison de la ville un nom
avant d'éclore sous nos yeux ravis les
plantations existe d'abord sur une
planche à dessin les compositions
naissent dans ce bureau d'études âme si
on re le plan d'aménagement d'un îlot
directionnel d'une des places de dijon
où le massif a été dessinée
plusieurs mois al avance et avec la
répartition exacte des fleurs qui seront
ensuite cultivées et plantées sur le
terrain de juin à septembre par exemple
146 mille plants de 50 espèces
différentes sont utilisés 200 points
forts et 234 fleurissent la ville un
conte position préférée pour moi sur les
compositions libre celle qui on a un
côté assez naturel
j'essaye de
faire en sorte qu' il ya de la vie dans
les massifs et qu' il ya une certaine
spontanéité un peu dans notre recherche
en général
actuellement les espaces verts préparent
les décors doc tonnes et les serres et
celles déjà quelques-unes des plantes
prévu pour florissimo 90 la grande
exposition florale de mars prochain
le motif de la place darcy y fait
référence avec le toucan fétiche soit
100 exposants y sont attendus dont 20
pays étrangers